(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Eu já falei em um momento anterior aqui
do curso que é muito importante a gente
analisar a viabilidade financeira daquela arrematação que a
gente está pesquisando.
O primeiro passo que você vai fazer sempre
é calcular o valor de mercado do imóvel
para saber se o valor de desconto que
está sendo oferecido no leilão realmente vale a
pena você participar ou não daquele leilão.
Então você vai fazer essa pesquisa de mercado
e aí você vai saber se o desconto
que está sendo oferecido é realmente vantajoso ou
não.
Quando a gente arremata com a finalidade de
investimento é importante que a gente tenha uma
margem maior de desconto para que a gente
consiga lucrar com aquele negócio.
Para quem for arrematar com uma finalidade de
moradia essa margem de desconto ela pode ser
um pouco menor já que ainda assim você
considerando o desconto aplicado em relação ao valor
de mercado vai ser algo vantajoso porque você
vai comprar um imóvel para moradia pagando menos
do que o mercado comercializa pelaquele imóvel, do
que o mercado cobra efetivamente por aquele imóvel.
Agora para investimento não, a gente precisa realmente
dessa margem maior.
Então por isso que a gente precisa fazer
uma simulação dos gastos que a gente vai
ter com a aquisição daquele imóvel.
Quando a gente compra um imóvel em leilão
e no mercado tradicional também existem alguns gastos
que envolvem essa compra como o pagamento do
ITBI.
O ITBI é o Imposto de Transmissão de
Bens Imóveis entre Pessoas Vivas.
É um imposto municipal com cada município ali
aplicando a sua alíquota que via de regra
fica entre 2% e 3%, mas existem
alguns municípios que cobram mais pelo ITBI.
Tem alguns municípios que chegam a cobrar 5
% do valor da compra do imóvel pelo
ITBI.
Como a gente tem mais de 5 mil
municípios no Brasil fica inviável listar aqui a
alíquota de todos esses municípios espalhados aí pelo
Brasil.
Então quando você for fazer uma arrematação em
determinado município pesquise qual é a alíquota de
ITBI aplicada para aquele município.
Isso aí com uma rápida pesquisa no Google
você consegue encontrar e aí você já consegue
fazer certinho o cálculo que você vai pagar
de ITBI.
Tem também custos com o registro do imóvel.
Esses custos com o registro do imóvel eles
são variáveis de estado para estado.
Cada estado tem a sua própria tabela com
esses custos.
Eu deixei aqui nos anexos dessa aula o
arquivo com todas as tabelas de todos os
estados do país.
Você vai abrir o arquivo do estado onde
você quer arrematar e aí você vai procurar
lá o valor do registro para você colocar
na calculadora do leilão.
Esses valores do registro eles mudam de acordo
com faixas de preço.
Então você precisa analisar dentro do valor que
você vai pagar por aquele imóvel qual é
a faixa de preço que se aplica para
o registro daquele imóvel.
Isso é algo muito importante que você deve
fazer também porque todo o custo deve ser
ali antecipado para você botar aqui na calculadora
do leilão e assim saber se aquela arrematação
vai ser vantajosa ou não.
Quando a gente arremata um imóvel em leilão
a gente também deve pagar a comissão do
leiloeiro.
Essa comissão do leiloeiro em regra é 5
% do valor da arrematação.
Existem casos em que a comissão do leiloeiro
pode ficar um pouco menor ou um pouco
maior, como por exemplo em um leilão judicial
às vezes é comum em imóveis de elevado
valor que o juiz determine que o percentual
da alíquota do comissão do leiloeiro deve ficar
um pouco menor, por entender que se ficasse
em 5% o leiloeiro receberia muito dinheiro
para fazer aquele serviço e aí o juiz
ele pode diminuir em alguns casos.
A comissão do leiloeiro ela sempre vai estar
prevista no edital do leilão, então ao ler
o edital, algo que a gente deve sempre
fazer antes de participar de um leilão de
imóvel, você vai verificar qual é a alíquota
que está sendo aplicada para a comissão do
leiloeiro ali naquela arrematação.
Vê de regra 5% do valor da
arrematação.
Quando a gente vende um imóvel a gente
também tem custos na venda desse imóvel.
Quais seriam esses custos?
Quando a gente vende um imóvel através de
um corretor de imóveis, algo que eu sempre
utilizo nos meus imóveis e recomendo que vocês
também façam, porque apesar de a gente ter
que pagar a comissão do corretor, o corretor
ele pode abreviar em muito o tempo de
venda do nosso imóvel, porque os corretores de
imóveis são profissionais que trabalham com venda de
imóveis todos os dias e conhecem ali um
ciclo de pessoas interessadas em comprar um imóvel.
Então esse é um profissional muito aliado de
quem quer arrematar imóveis em leilão, justamente porque
esse profissional pode abreviar em muito o tempo
da venda do seu imóvel.
Então você já calcula previamente que você vai
pagar a comissão do corretor na venda daquele
imóvel.
A comissão do corretor também varia de estado
para estado.
No geral fica entre 5 e 6%
do valor da venda.
Aqui em São Paulo, por exemplo, a comissão
do corretor é de 6% sobre o
valor da venda do imóvel.
Pesquise no estado onde você quer arrematar e
depois vender o imóvel quanto é o percentual
do corretor na venda do imóvel e já
coloque na calculadora do leilão.
Por acaso, se você vender o imóvel ali
através de uma venda direta, sem o auxílio
de um corretor, o que vai acontecer é
que você vai lucrar ainda mais do que
você estava planejando, porque você vai deixar de
pagar esse custo.
Então toda vez que vou fazer a minha
viabilidade financeira de algum leilão, eu já coloco
previamente a comissão do corretor.
Se por acaso surgir uma venda direta, eu
lucro ainda mais do que eu estava esperando,
não existe nenhum prejuízo quanto a isso, pelo
contrário, vai ser algo ainda mais benéfico.
Na venda do imóvel também, a gente deve
pagar o imposto de renda sobre o lucro
imobiliário.
Lá no módulo 4, a gente vai ter
uma aula exclusiva sobre o imposto de renda
no lucro imobiliário, quais são as formas de
isenção, se vale mais a pena arrematar como
pessoa física ou como pessoa jurídica.
O objetivo aqui é realmente falar que você
deve pagar o imposto de renda sobre o
lucro imobiliário e você já deve calcular isso
previamente também, porque isso é algo que vai
impactar no seu lucro e pra saber certinho
a margem de lucro que você espera daquele
negócio, você deve colocar todos os gastos.
Aqui na calculadora do leilão que eu desenvolvi,
o campo de imposto de renda, ele já
está lá com uma alíquota preenchida de 15%,
por quê?
Porque como vamos ver no módulo 4, o
imposto de renda para pessoas físicas tem essa
alíquota de 15% sobre o lucro imobiliário
para ganhos de até 5 milhões, então aí
é basicamente a porcentagem que vai se aplicar
na venda da maioria de vocês, por isso
que já tem lá o campo de 15
% preenchido, mas esse campo você consegue mudar
na calculadora, caso na sua venda tenha uma
alíquota diferente, lá na aula de imposto de
renda no módulo 4, eu apresento todas as
alíquotas que incidem dependendo da faixa de preço
do lucro imobiliário.
Então, com o objetivo de reunir todas essas
informações, eu desenvolvi a calculadora do leilão, que
é uma calculadora que eu uso em todas
as minhas arrematações também, para já calcular esses
gastos que a gente vai ter com a
arrematação do imóvel e depois com a venda
do imóvel.
Outro gasto muito importante que você deve considerar,
é o gasto que você vai ter para
a manutenção daquele imóvel, e aí quando eu
falo de manutenção, eu estou falando de duas
coisas, em primeiro lugar, algum valor ali que
você pode gastar com reforma daquele imóvel, né,
via de regra nos meus imóveis, eu não
costumo fazer reformas complexas, como a gente vai
falar lá no módulo 4 em uma aula
específica, eu sempre tento baratear ao máximo esses
custos com reformas, geralmente eu faço somente uma
simples pintura no imóvel, em alguns casos mais
complexos, como uma droga de piso, eu também
sempre faço a opção pela via mais barata,
mas é importante que você calcule ali previamente,
algo para a reforma do imóvel, como é
que você vai levantar as informações sobre o
estado de conservação, a gente já falou aqui
em um ponto anterior do curso, caso você
não consiga nenhuma informação, você pode ali calcular
uma reforma simples através da metragem do imóvel
do ano de construção, então com isso você
já tira ali uma média do que você
deve gastar com uma reforma ou com algum
reparo simples naquele imóvel.
Obviamente quando a gente fala de reforma, é
muito difícil de forma antecipada, ainda mais para
quem vai iniciar aí no mercado imobiliário por
agora, que não tem uma experiência com reformas
anteriores, é muito difícil a gente cravar ali
um preço específico, mas por isso que você
vai botar uma média para também isso não
abalar o seu lucro depois que você gastar
algum valor, porque você já estava de forma
antecipada contando com aquele valor.
Você também deve considerar um prazo de venda
razoável para o imóvel, pode ser que você
arremate um imóvel em um mês e consiga
dois meses depois vender aquele imóvel, mas essa
definitivamente não é a regra do mercado imobiliário.
Quando a gente fala de compra e venda
de um imóvel, a gente precisa de fato
pensar em um prazo real de venda.
Por que esse prazo deve existir?
Porque enquanto o imóvel estiver ali em sua
titularidade, você for de fato proprietário daquele imóvel,
você vai ter gastos com aquele imóvel, gastos
mensais.
Quando a gente fala de um apartamento ou
de uma casa de condomínio, a gente tem
que pagar condomínio todo mês e o IPTU,
que apesar de ser um imposto anual, as
pessoas parcelam e pagam mês a mês.
Se for uma casa de rua, você também
vai ter o gasto com o IPTU, apesar
de não existir esse gasto de condomínio, mas
você também deve calcular isso previamente para já
saber quanto você terá de retorno, de lucro
líquido com a compra e venda daquele imóvel
arrematado e também para saber quanto você vai
precisar de capital para manter aquele imóvel durante
a sua titularidade.
Você precisa de um prazo real, então, para
calcular essas despesas.
O que eu considero como prazo real?
Eu sempre considero nas minhas arrematações, seja para
arrematações próprias ou seja para a consultoria, um
prazo de 12 meses da arrematação até a
venda.
Na minha prática, esse prazo tem se mostrado,
de fato, um prazo muito real para você
arrematar, desocupar o imóvel, regularizar a documentação e
vender aquele imóvel.
Então, previamente, eu sempre calculo que eu vou
ter o gasto de 12 meses de condomínio
e de IPTU nas minhas arrematações.
Bom, feita toda essa análise, agora a parte
prática, que é a parte de realmente colocar
esses valores na calculadora do leilão e saber
se aquela arrematação vai ser vantajosa.
E também na calculadora do leilão, o objetivo
é que você brinque com os valores máximos
da arrematação para encontrar o máximo de lance
que você pode oferecer naquele leilão.
A gente nunca deve entrar em um leilão
sem ter bem definido o lance máximo que
a gente deve oferecer.
Por quê?
Porque a gente pode participar de leilão que
não vai ter concorrência nenhuma, ou a gente
pode participar de leilão que vai ter concorrência
um lance após o outro.
Isso é algo bem dinâmico.
Então, o objetivo de ter sempre bem definido
o lance máximo que você pode oferecer, é
saber até que momento você pode chegar e
parar quando chegar ali no seu lance máximo,
se for o caso, em determinado leilão.
No meio do leilão, um lance após o
outro, é normal a gente ficar um pouco
nervoso, é normal ser tomado por uma adrenalina,
afinal de contas, o leilão não deixa de
ser uma disputa e é uma disputa por
um bem de um valor um pouco mais
elevado, como é um imóvel.
Então, a gente não pode deixar essa emoção
tirar a nossa razão para fazer uma compra
muito vantajosa, uma compra muito lucrativa.
Então, sempre determine o lance máximo que você
pode oferecer naquele imóvel e isso você vai
fazer através da calculadora do leilão, que está
disponível em anexo aqui nessa aula, para que
todos vocês façam o download e usem em
todos os leilões que vocês forem analisar.
Vamos aqui, então, passar ao funcionamento da calculadora
do leilão.
Então, está aqui o arquivo da calculadora.
Vocês podem observar que tem duas abas, uma
para pagamento à vista e outra para pagamento
financiado.
Vou começar aqui pelo pagamento à vista.
Primeira coisa que você vai preencher é o
valor de arrematação e aí você vai começar
pelo valor mínimo do leilão para depois você
ir mudando esses valores de acordo com a
margem de lucro que você espera.
Vamos supor aqui que você está analisando um
leilão de um imóvel de R$ 400
mil, que foi avaliado em R$ 400
mil e ele está indo a leilão em
segunda praça ou em segundo leilão exclujiticial, pelo
valor mínimo de R$ 200 mil.
Então, você vai preencher aqui R$ 200
mil.
O valor de venda você vai botar ali
R$ 400 mil, que é, de fato,
a pesquisa que você fez do valor de
mercado desse imóvel.
Você viu que o valor que está lá
no leilão, o valor de avaliação, realmente está
certinho e aí você pode contar com esse
valor.
Comissão do leiloeiro, a calculadora já bota aqui
automaticamente 5%.
Se por acaso a alíquota for diferente, aí
você vai mudar a alíquota, mas como no
geral é 5%, por isso que esse valor
já está aqui.
ITBI, que é o Imposto Municipal de Transmissão
de Bens Imóveis, com alíquotas variáveis de município
para município, você deve verificar qual é a
alíquota que incide ali no município onde você
quer arrematar.
Vamos supor que esse imóvel aqui que a
gente está analisando é aqui em São Paulo
e aqui em São Paulo a alíquota do
ITBI é de 3%.
Então, preenche 3% automaticamente.
A calculadora já me apresenta que eu vou
pagar R$ 6 mil de ITBI.
Para o registro de um imóvel nesse valor
de R$ 200 mil de compra aqui
em São Paulo, que eu falei que o
registro ele muda de estado para estado, dentro
de faixas de preço de acordo com o
imóvel, aqui em São Paulo esse registro ficaria
em R$ 1930, aproximadamente.
Então, preenche aqui.
Valor de advogado para desocupação desse imóvel.
Vamos supor que esse imóvel é um imóvel
de um leilão excrediticial e nesse imóvel você
conseguiu fazer um acordo ali, então você, nesse
acordo amigável, como a gente vai estudar melhor
no módulo 2, que é o módulo de
leilões excrediticiais, você não vai precisar pagar nenhum
valor de advogado porque você realmente entrou em
um acordo ali para desocupação.
Então, vamos deixar zerado.
Reforma.
Vamos supor que nesse imóvel aqui você vai
fazer alguns reparos básicos como uma pintura e
ali retoques estéticos muito pequenos nesse imóvel.
Vamos supor que você vai gastar R$
3.000,00 de reforma.
No campo de outros, o que que entra
aqui?
Eu fiz uma simulação aqui anteriormente de que
nesse imóvel você fez um acordo para que
ele fosse desocupado e aí vamos supor que
nesse acordo você combinou pagar a mudança de
quem estava ocupando o imóvel e essa mudança
custou R$ 1.000,00.
Então, você vai botar aqui no campo de
outros.
Prazo de venda, como eu falei, eu sempre
calculo 12 meses e aqui vamos simular um
IPTU mensal de R$ 100,00.
A própria calculadora já vai multiplicar o valor
que você vai precisar durante esses 12 meses
para pagar o IPTU, R$ 1.200
,00 e vamos supor que o condomínio mensal
desse apartamento que a gente vai arrematar por
R$ 200,00 é R$ 400
,00 e aí a própria calculadora já bota
que nesse prazo total de 12 meses você
vai gastar R$ 4.800,00 de
condomínio e a calculadora já soma condomínio e
IPTU.
Então, repare que aqui a calculadora vai te
apresentar a soma do total dos custos, que
são todos esses custos acima, incluindo o valor
da arrematação, comissão do leiloeiro, ITBI, registro do
imóvel, valor do advogado, se for o caso,
reforma, o campo de outros, se for o
caso e o prazo de venda com IPTU
mensal e condomínio mensal e aí pra você
manter esse imóvel da arrematação até a venda,
incluindo o valor da arrematação, você precisaria de
um total de R$ 227.930,00.
Depois a calculadora, ela tem uns campos aqui
que são aplicáveis para a venda desse imóvel,
então como a gente está fazendo a simulação
que esse imóvel aqui fica em São Paulo,
em São Paulo a comissão do corretor é
de 6%, então a calculadora já vai me
dar o valor aqui que eu pagaria R
$ 24.000,00 para um corretor na
venda desse imóvel.
O que eu falei anteriormente é que você
pode vender o imóvel sem o auxílio do
corretor, o que eu recomendo que você faça
é contratar o corretor porque isso pode abreviar
em muito tempo da sua venda, então previamente
eu sempre calculo a comissão do corretor, se
por acaso surgisse uma venda direta, eu iria
tirar essa comissão do corretor e lucraria mais
R$ 24.000,00.
Depois a calculadora já bota aqui o imposto
sobre o ganho de capital, já tem uma
alíquota de 15% que como eu expliquei
é a alíquota que vai incidir para pessoas
físicas em um montante de até R$
5 milhões de lucro imobiliário.
Então já está aqui 15% e a
calculadora ela já me apresenta o valor que
eu vou pagar de imposto de renda.
Aqui só uma observação, a aula completa lá
de imposto de renda está no módulo 4,
mas vou adiantar que a calculadora aqui ela
já abate o que você pode considerar como
o seu custo de aquisição, isso aí você
pode abater do seu lucro imobiliário, como de
fato o valor que você pagou pelo imóvel
que no nosso caso vai ser o valor
da arrematação, você também pode abater a comissão
do leiloeiro, você pode abater os gastos com
registro, com ITBI, com reforma e você também
pode abater a comissão do corretor.
Então quando a calculadora bota esses 15%
aqui representado em um valor em reais, ela
já está considerando o abatimento desses outros custos
que também podem entrar ali para você diminuir
o imposto de renda que você vai pagar.
Então pronto, a calculadora vai me apresentar que
aqui eu vou ter um imposto de renda
de um pouco mais de 23 mil para
pagar na compra e venda desse imóvel e
óbvio que também existem casos de isenção de
imposto de renda, esses casos vão ser estudados
a fundo também lá no módulo 4, se
fosse o caso seria só você zerar aqui
o imposto de renda e deixar zerado que
o seu lucro líquido também seria calculado certinho,
mas nesse caso aqui vamos supor que a
gente vai pagar o imposto de renda.
A calculadora por fim, ela apresenta esse valor
real da venda.
O que eu chamo de valor real da
venda?
O valor que de fato vai entrar no
seu bolso quando você vender o imóvel.
Então a comissão do corretor não vai entrar
no seu bolso, vai direto para o corretor
e o imposto de renda ele é um
valor que vai entrar no seu bolso, mas
logo depois ele vai sair então você também
não pode considerar que você vai ficar com
aquele valor do imposto de renda, por isso
que eu considero um valor real da venda
que é o valor da venda de fato,
diminuindo a comissão do corretor e o imposto
de renda e aí a pessoa ficaria efetivamente
com 352.739 reais e 50 centavos.
Esse é o valor que de fato vai
ficar no seu bolso que corresponde à volta
dessa soma total de custos aqui, que você
gastou para arrematar o imóvel, regularizar o imóvel
e manter o imóvel até a venda e
o valor de lucro.
Se a gente arrematasse por 200 e vendesse
por 400, considerando todos os custos envolvidos nessa
compra, a gente teria um lucro líquido de
124.809 reais e 50 centavos, correspondendo a
uma porcentagem de lucro de 54% de
lucro líquido, lucro líquido exatamente porque na calculadora
a gente colocou aqui todos os gastos incluindo
os gastos de venda como corretor e imposto
de renda, então olha como o leilão ele
pode ser algo muito vantajoso para você comprar
um imóvel com grande desconto e ainda assim
lucrar bastante.
O objetivo então aqui da calculadora é você
brincar com esse valor da arrematação de acordo
com o lucro líquido que você espera ter
dessa compra e venda.
Vamos supor que no seu caso você acha
interessante comprar e vender esse imóvel considerando todos
os custos e ficar com um lucro líquido
de 30% na sua mão.
Então você vai começar a simular aqui o
valor de arrematação máxima que você pode oferecer.
Vamos supor aqui que você coloque 220 mil
reais.
Quando você muda o valor da arrematação a
calculadora automaticamente vai mudar a comissão do leiloeiro,
o ITBI e esses valores aqui na venda,
comissão do corretor e o imposto de renda
sobre o lucro imobiliário.
O que a calculadora não vai mudar?
O valor do registro porque você deve olhar
na tabela para saber dentro da faixa de
preço dos imóveis qual é o valor de
registro que você vai pagar e aí se
por acaso esse valor de registro mudasse de
200 para 220 mil na faixa lá do
estado onde você quer arrematar, você coloca o
novo valor de registro aqui.
Se por acaso ficar dentro da mesma faixa
você não vai precisar mudar.
E esses outros valores aqui eles não vão
mudar dependendo do valor que você pagar para
aquele imóvel.
O valor de reforma vai ser o mesmo,
o valor de outros ali seria o mesmo
e o prazo de venda com esse custo
do prazo de venda é o mesmo porque
independente se você comprar um imóvel por 200
ou 300 mil o IPTU dele é fixo
mensal e o condomínio dele também é fixo
mensal então não muda.
Então mudando para 220 a calculadora apresenta um
lucro líquido ali de 42%, quase 43%.
Mudando para 250 mil a calculadora vai me
apresentar ali um lucro líquido de praticamente 28%.
Então o objetivo é que você fique brincando
aqui com esse valor da arrematação para que
você saiba quanto que você pode oferecer de
lance máximo dentro da margem de lucro líquido
que você espera e aí você define esse
lance máximo e para quando chegar no seu
lance máximo.